[Música]
México acusó al consejo de seguridad de
Naciones Unidas de vivir en una
parálisis ante la guerra en Ucrania en
Boca de su canciller Marcelo ebrard el
país latinoamericano propuso reformar a
fondo este organismo de la ONU incluso
eliminando el derecho de veto cuando se
trate de crímenes masivos México propone
una comitiva de jefes de estado como
mediadores incluyendo al Vaticano
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quiere avanzar en su propuesta de una
paz total el mandatario aseguró que es
cuestión de días para plantear un cc
multilateral del juego para conseguir el
fin de la violencia en el país
en Brasil a poco más de una semana de la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales una encuesta refuerza el
favoritismo de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva sobre el actual mandatario Yair
bolsonaro el izquierdista lidera ahora
con 14 puntos de margen
actualizamos la información aquí en la
pantalla de France 24 Mi nombre es Juan
pupiales Estas son las noticias a más
destacadas del continente americano
México intervino este jueves en Naciones
Unidas y lo hizo ante el pleno de la
asamblea general El canciller mexicano
Marcelo ebrard llegó con una propuesta
En nombre del presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador para para lograr la paz en
Ucrania abogó por una reforma del
Consejo de Seguridad al que señaló de
parálisis y propuso una comitiva de
jefes de estado que incluiría entre
otros al Papa Francisco para ayudar al
secretario general de la ONU en los
esfuerzos de mediación
ante la parálisis del Consejo de
Seguridad
debemos ofrecer entre todos un canal
diplomático complementario los
existentes para interactuar con las
partes en conflicto con miras a reducir
las tensiones y en causar la mediación
indispensable
esta propuesta ha sido compartida En
días pasados con el secretario general y
con las partes involucradas así como con
las delegaciones de la India y de la
santa sede toda vez que el presidente
López Obrador considera que en dicha
comitiva debieran participar junto con
el secretario general de la ONU entre
otros su excelencia en adentro modi y su
santidad del Papa Francisco
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en Ciudad de México Mario
carbonell que nos entregó más detalles
acerca de esta propuesta del gobierno
mexicano y que llevaron ante Naciones
Unidas
Sí bueno este plan parte de un
diagnóstico que hace el presidente López
Obrador en el sentido de que el consejo
de seguridad de la ONU está paralizado
que no logró evitar un conflicto bélico
no está pudiendo frenar la guerra y
tampoco garantizar el acceso al mercado
de granos básicos de fertilizantes ni la
llegada de la ayuda humanitaria Es por
ello que plantea crear una comitiva
internacional integrada por jefes de
gobierno y jefes de estado entre ellos
el Primer Ministro de la India narendra
modi y el Papa Francisco
una especie de Cocos que sea un canal
diplomático que complemente los ya
existentes en aras de llegar a una
solución del conflicto
Aquí también el presidente López Obrador
ha sometido esta propuesta a distintos
jefes de estado al propio Antonio
Gutiérrez según Marcelo ebrard lo han
sometido
en consideración del jefe del secretario
general de la ONU y están a la espera de
que esto pueda conformarse es este el
proyecto que se tiene desde México
y seguimos hablando de México hombres no
identificados abrieron fuego
indiscriminadamente en un bar de
Guanajuato dejando 10 personas muertas
el gobernador del estado Diego cime
Rodríguez aseguró que la fuerza pública
está comprometida a dar con el paradero
de los responsables Se confirmó que
todas las víctimas en el hecho de
violencia eran hombres 9 murieron en la
escena y otro falleció horas después en
un hospital local Guanajuato en el
centro del territorio es el estado
mexicano que más muertes violentas ha
registrado en 2022 con 2.500 víctimas
entre enero y agosto
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
afirmó desde Nueva York que es cuestión
de días para plantear un posible
escenario de un cc multilateral del
fuego el mandatario tiene como bandera
de su gobierno la denominada paz total
con la que busca poner fin a la
violencia en el territorio escuchamos el
presidente
es cuestión de días Y en cuestión de
días también se va a plantear un tema
público
la posibilidad de un cc multilateral del
fuego que sería el inicio del fin de la
violencia en Colombia cese multilateral
significa que las diversas actores que
son múltiples
cesan de disparar
previamente hablamos con Camilo González
pozo presidente del instituto de
estudios para el desarrollo y la paz
indepaz quien nos habló del tamaño del
que serían las negociaciones para sss el
juego multilateral al que se refería el
presidente Gustavo Petro
importantísimo el anuncio que hace el
presidente porque eso indica que lo que
estaba previsto por algunos algo para el
próximo año se va a anticipar ahí
intervienen organizaciones que se llaman
disidentes que no entraron o se
imaginaron el proceso de las FARC el Ln
también el llamado clan del Golfo
herederos del panamericanismo son cerca
de 22
estructuras de este tipo que se han
pronunciado a favor de estas
conversaciones aparte de de digamos de
otras menores y esto tendría un impacto
extraordinario en la sociedad colombiana
No es fácil porque son grupos muy
dispersos que no tienen un consolidados
mandos y no Son estructuras digamos
verticales unificadas pero es viable y
sobre todo tendrá gran impacto en la
sociedad colombiana
de Cara a la primera vuelta de las
elecciones en Brasil el expresidente
Luis Ignacio violada Silva sigo
aumentando su ventaja en las encuestas
ante el actual mandatario Yair
bolsonaron de acuerdo a los más
recientes sondeos de Data [__] Lula
llegó a 14 puntos de ventaja en la
primera vuelta ante el actual mandatario
contaría con un 47% de los apoyos frente
al 33% de evolucionaron las mismas
encuestas apuntan a que una eventual
segunda vuelta le daría la victoria a la
izquierda está con un 54% frente a un
38% del presidente que busca la
reelección y que ha lanzado acusaciones
sin pruebas contra la integridad del
sistema de Voto electrónico en el
gigante suramericano
hay un 20 o 30% de votantes de la
ultraderecha que aboga por el presidente
Yahir bolsonaro que no aceptará De
ninguna manera el resultado electoral y
la voluntad de la mayoria
nuestra mejor opción tuvimos un partido
el partido de los trabajadores que
corrompió todas las áreas El poder
legislativo El Ejecutivo y también el
judicial desgraciadamente casi acabó con
nuestro país
y Feliz Navidad
en El Salvador este jueves se reportaron
al menos siete fallecidos a causa de los
deslizamientos de tierra causados por
las Fuertes lluvias las autoridades de
Protección Civil anunciaron que 5 de
esas personas fallecieron en las
localidades de wishucar en el centro del
país según este organismo en septiembre
las lluvias dejan al menos 160
deslizamientos 38 viviendas dañadas y 16
Ríos desbordados
en Estados Unidos de acuerdo con un
estudio si la comunidad latina fuera un
país independiente su aporte económico
tendría el quinto producto interno bruto
más grande del mundo según el informe de
la firma latitud los latinos que son
casi el 19% de la población de Estados
Unidos aportan más que economías como
Italia o Brasil el estudio muestra que
entre 2010 y 2020 el pib de los latinos
en Estados Unidos Fue el tercero de
crecimiento más rápido entre los 10
mayores del mundo Incluso un 21% más
rápido de que la India y un 30% más
rápido que China
terminamos hablando de nuevo de Colombia
la capital Bogotá celebró este 22 de
Septiembre el día del aire limpio
conocido popularmente como el día sin
carro en esta jornada los vehículos
privados tienen prohibida la circulación
entre las 6:30 de la mañana y las 7:30
de la noche sin embargo siguen en
funcionamiento unos 8.000 buses y otros
50.000 taxis para asegurar la movilidad
de los bogotanos y además de colaborar
con el medio ambiente al menos por un
día al año los sean residentes de una de
las ciudades con el peor tráfico del
mundo pueden soñar con una urbe donde
circular con rapidez no sea cosa de
fantasías
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
aquí en la pantalla de France 24 Pero
quédense porque la información continúa
Aquí también en Francia 24.com
[Música]